,
THEY SEE WEAKNESS AND NONSTOP
FAILURES AND THEY KNOW DARN WELL
HE'S NOT UP TO THE JOB.
HERE WITH REACTION AUTHOR OF THE
NUMBER ONE BEST SELLER FORMER
COUNSEL OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
KELLYANNE CONWAY ALONG WITH
FORMER TRUMP CHIEF OF STAFF
MARK MEADOWS.
IT'S LIKE A SERIES WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" GOING AFTER
JOE BIDEN HE CAN'T RUN THE
POLICIES AND THEY ARE NOT
WORKING.
THEY ALMOST KIND OF DESERVED TO
GIVE ME CREDIT AND SAY HANNITY
WAS RIGHT ALL ALONG ABOUT THE
GUY BUT I DON'T SEE THE DAY
COMING BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT
POLLSTERS SELLING NOTHING BUT A
HOAX AND CONSPIRACY THEORY.
>> IT'S ALL QUITE CURIOUS AND
HERE'S MY TAKE.
IT'S NOT JUST TODAY'S POLL OR
NEXT MONTH POLL, THEY KNOW THAT
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS ARE
COMPLETELY DAMAGED GOODS.
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING PAST BOTH
OF THEM AND LOOKING AT 2024.
THIS GUY HAS BEEN HERE FOR A
YEAR AND A HALF.
HE'S GOT THE ENERGY, LOOK AT HIM
GO, HE'S GOT THE MENTAL ACUITY.
NOW THEY'RE DONE WITH HIM AND I
THINK THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AND THAT
HE LIED ABOUT TALKING TO HIS SON
ABOUT CHINA AND THAT HE LIED
ABOUT FAMILY MEMBERS MAKING
MONEY BECAUSE THEY WERE
CONNECTED TO HIM AND HIM TAKING
GOVERNMENT PLANE ARE BROUGHT
DOING THAT.
THEY KNOW IT'S A STORM COMING
AND WE ARE ABOUT FIVE OR SIX
WEEKS AWAY FROM THE ONE-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY ANNIVERSARY OF THE
DEADLY CHAOTIC WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
INTELLIGENCE AND EQUIPMENT
WITHIN THE WINGSPAN OF CHINA
TURNED OVER TO THE TALIBAN AND
AFGHANISTAN.
WOMEN HAVE FEWER RIGHTS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A FEMALE VICE PRESIDENT
WHO CAN'T SPEAK FOR THEM.
THEY KNOW ALL OF THIS IS COMING
AND THE SECOND HALF OF 2022 WILL
BE EVEN WORSE THAN THE
FIRST HALF.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND LET ME
TELL YOU QUICKLY, NOTORIOUSLY
PRO-DEMOCRAT, PRO-2015,
PRO-BIDEN 2020.
GOING TO WIN BY 61-16, KANSAS BY
71, 14.
IT JOE BIDEN IT'S TO WIN BY ALL
OHIO.
LIST GOES ON AND ON, THE
SAMPLINGS ARE NOT GREAT FOR
REPUBLICAN AND ITS THEY ARE
POLL, 64% OF DEMOCRATS WANT SOME
OF THE BEYOND JOE BIDEN IN 2024
AND 94% ESSENTIALLY EVERYONE,
94% OF DEMOCRATS UNDER THE AGE
OF 30 WANT SOMEONE OTHER THAN
JOE BIDEN.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT 24 AND
NOBODY IS GOING TO GO WITH HIM.
>> Sean: I THINK HE'S DONE, I
THINK HE'S BEEN PUSHED OUT.
AND HE DOESN'T KNOW YET, IS IN A
PRIME CANDIDATE OR
ELIZABETH WARREN.
I WONDER WHO'S SUFFERING THE
MOST UNDER THE POLICIES.
BEFORE THE MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE.
SO MUCH OF THIS IS ROOTED IN THE
IDEA THAT WE CAN IMPORT OIL FROM
RUSSIA, IRAN, VENEZUELA, OPEC,
THE SAUDIS, BUT NOT PRODUCE
ENERGY DOMESTICALLY KNOWING THAT
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF
SUPPLY WHERE WE CAN BE SELF
SELF-SUFFICIENT.
I HAVE A HARD TIME UNDERSTANDING
THE LOGIC IN ALLOWING GAS PRICES
AND ENERGY PRICES AND EVERYTHING
ELSE GO SKY HIGH.
>> MADE IN AMERICA IS GOOD FOR
ENERGY AS WELL, SEAN, YOU KNOW
THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE POLES THAT
KELLYANNE CONWAY WAS REFERRING
TO, ONE HAS 13% OF AMERICANS
BELIEVE WE'RE HEADED IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
THAT'S PRETTY BAD PERFORMANCE
FOR JOE BIDEN, BUT HERE'S THE
INTERESTING THING.
YOU COULD ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT, BUT HE IS PLAYING TO
THE LEFT, THE DONORS IN
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK, DONORS IN
BOSTON.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THEY WANT THE
PROGRESSIVE GREEN ENERGY KIND OF
SOLUTIONS AND YET WHAT HE CAN DO
IS FAST TRACK DRILLING IN
AMERICA.
THEY SAID WE HAVE ALLOWED MORE
LEAD TO HAPPEN, YES, THEY HAVE,
YET WE CAN LOWER PRICES.
I TALKED TO A GUY THE OTHER DAY,
HE SAYS I'M HAVING TO FILL UP
HIS TRUCK EACH AND EVERY WEEK
AND IT'S A REMINDER, A CONSTANT
REMINDER THAT SOMEBODY COULD DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
IN HIS WORDS, DONALD TRUMP DID
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT IF WE GET
HIM BACK IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Sean: WESTERN FOR BOTH OF
YOU.
WHAT DO DEMOCRATS DO IN 2024?
>> LOSE.
IF THEY ARE GOING TO LOSE.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP HAS A
BETTER CHANCE OF BEING THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE THAN
JOE BIDEN HAS OF BEING THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE RIGHT NOW AND
JULY OF 2022.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
THEY ARGUE WITH EACH OTHER.
TERRIBLY BECAUSE THEY WENT
BACKWARDS, TWO POLITICAL
OUTSIDERS, THEN WE WENT
BACKWARDS WITH THE LOCH NESS
MONSTER OVER THE SWAMP.
PETE BUTTIGIEG AND KAMALA HARRIS
RUINS THEMSELVES BY BEING IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: MARK MEADOWS IN YOUR
MIND, WHO WOULD BE THE
REPLACEMENT?
>> THEY'RE GOING TO LURCH TO THE
LEFT AND THEY ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE -- YOU'LL HEAR
ELIZABETH WARREN'S NAME A LOT
MORE THAN YOU HAVE.
WE ARE ABOUT TO ENTER INTO THIS
60 DAYS OF BLAME AND SHAME.
BLAME THE DEMOCRATS, THE
REPUBLICANS, BLAME EVERYBODY BUT
DEMOCRATS.
HOLD YOUR HEAD LOW AND SUGGEST
THAT YOU HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
BECAUSE OF RESULTS.
WHAT WE WILL ULTIMATELY SEE IS
JOE BIDEN BOWING OUT AND THEY
WILL DISTANCE THEMSELVES AND
HOPE THEY CAN RECLAIM CONGRESS
AFTER THE